we spent the past two days embedded with
the Border Patrol on the ground and in
the air and on the water and you're
gonna be shocked by some of what the
Border Patrol showed us and here's just
a little of what we were able to see for
ourselves most of the time you can walk
across the river into those places but
again that's where it is deceptive
you see oh I can walk on this and
suddenly they reach its pop words over
their head
current is strong and they get swept
away you'll have a mother come out and
trying to hold her baby above her head
for the small children above their heads
and then
you'll see the mother is trying to
struggle herself as she's fighting the
current trying to keep a child above our
heads and then they both just can't make
it if they're lucky they make it back to
the island and wait for help they're not
lucky than they end up downstream
you can see the broken cane right on the
bank and on the thing that's broken as
you looked up through there you see the
trash bags that they leave behind
they'll use those trash bags to keep
their clothes dry they also use the
trash bags this point see when they come
across they'll fill them up with air and
not them so this is a this is a landing
area
yes without that fat it's an easy
country river what the fence does is it
gives us that break then that spot they
have to slow down to give our agents
time to make first detected and to
respond in order to effect that arrest
[Music]
so these four run a two upriver and so
the boat unit had to go up there and
rescue them as you can tell we're all
soaking wet
poor people drowned the other day same
circumstances how did they know to cross
at this particular como se va pas de
Quesada Keeling in a silhouette you can
see we've had almost every size of
diaper you can imagine we've got
multiple kinds of formulas we've got
juices and snacks we've got meals we
partner up with some of our
non-governmental agencies and they will
they will help donate some clothing also
a lot of this is brought in by the
agents themselves we are parents so a
lot of the agents have two three four
kids when they outgrow these are the
hand-me-downs
here we are in the mail REO sector of
the border with the other two miles of
fencing is remember this whole area is
209 miles definitely helps nowhere near
enough